in Hollywood you're only ever as good as
your last film even if you've been
churning out hits for years on end all
it takes is one awful movie to take you
down a peg here's a look at some awful
films that put an end to an actor's hot
streak Serina when Jennifer Lawrence
stumbled up to the podium to collect her
Best Actress Oscar for 2012's silver
linings playbook
she was already several films into a hot
streak she'd turned in an impressive
performance in 2010's Winter's Bone and
made her first appearances in The Hunger
Games and x-men franchises after that
which collectively brought in over half
a billion dollars she got her third
Oscar nomination for her scene-stealing
role in American hustle in 2013 and
continued to make the whole blockbuster
thing look easy the following year with
Mockingjay part 1 like I said I know
exactly what I have to do
unfortunately her streak ended in tame
fashion in 2014 with the universally
panned serena which was rejected by
audiences critics and even film
distributors after a very limited
domestic release which netted under
$200,000 serena disappeared despite an
academy nod for joy the final Hunger
Games film turned out to be the lowest
earning of the lot and Lawrence's poll
has wavered ever since the great wall
american movie studios have known for a
while that China's box office has been
growing exponentially and some have
attempted to take advantage of the
Chinese market by altering their movies
to cater to overseas sensibilities
others have sought co-productions with
Chinese studios which is how Matt
Damon's the Great Wall came to be
legendary teamed up with the China Film
Group for what turned out to be an epic
disappointment grossing 45 million
dollars stateside director John emo
brought plenty of his famed visual flair
to the movie but it was critically
trashed both in the US and in China
the critical reaction wasn't good for
Damon who had been on a real hot streak
with roles in interstellar and the
Martian as well as a producer credit on
Manchester by the sea things haven't
exactly been going great for Damon since
he saw out 2017 with suburbicon and
downsizing to bizarre comedies that
premiered to mixed reviews at best The
Ladykillers
not many actors can claim to have
experienced a hot streak as long as the
one Tom Hanks enjoyed for the better
part of 15 years from the early 1990s to
the midpoint of the 2000s Hanks was a
guarantee
draw at the box office with his movies
rarely pulling in less than 100 million
dollars in that space of time he starred
in such critically acclaimed hits as
Philadelphia Forrest Gump
Apollo 13 Saving Private Ryan and many
many more somebody later tell me gay
people I don't know anything about that
it had to happen sometime but when Hanks
his bubble did eventually burst it was
unexpected nobody saw his hot streak
coming to an end with The Ladykillers
the idea of Hanks collaborating with the
Coen brothers on this 2004 remake of a
British classic seemed like a surefire
recipe for success that wasn't the case
however the movie barely recouped its 35
million dollar budget at the domestic
box office and was panned by many of the
industry's top critics the monuments men
he hasn't been able to hit that 100
million dollar mark quite as often as
Tom Hanks but George Clooney is also
known to bring in the big bucks on
occasion he generated major Bank
fronting Steven Soderbergh's popular in
highly profitable oceans movies and his
starring role in the critically panned
1997 Batman & Robin still managed to
bring in a cool 238 million dollars in
the late 2000s Clooney was undeniably
a-list but in 2014 his career took a
severe nosedive Clooney co-wrote
produced directed and starred in world
war two caper the monuments men a story
about a ragtag platoon sent into Nazi
Germany to retrieve stolen works of art
despite an all-star cast that included
Matt Damon Bill Murray and John Goodman
the movie bombed in theaters and took a
licking from the critics worse because
Clooney was so involved in the movies
production there were few other people
to blame besides the former Batman Free
State of Jones Matthew McConaughey's
career is a tale told in two acts after
years of depending on his looks and
charm to pay the bills with rom-com
after forgettable rom-com he decided to
start acting again and Hollywood
welcomed him back with open arms
dubbed the Makana sense at the time
McConaughey's turnaround can be traced
back to 2011's The Lincoln Lawyer which
scored highly with critics between his
2014 Best Actor win for Dallas buyers
club and his scene-stealing performances
in the wolf of Wall Street and
interstellar McConaughey seemed
unstoppable unfortunately you can't keep
making good choices forever and
Anna Hayes 2016 free state of Jones was
definitely not a good one the civil war
drama only managed to claw back half of
its 50 million dollar budget and the
majority of critics were unimpressed
worse his starring turned in 2017 s The
Dark Tower was similarly disliked
spelling the end of McConaughey's box
office domination no matter who crosses
the finish line first the universe will
die out eventually death always wins
King Arthur legend of the sword in 2002
Charlie Hunnam starred as Nicholas
Nickleby and a critically acclaimed
adaptation of the classic Dickens novel
and then showed his darker side in
2005's Green Street hooligans later
appearances in children of men's Sons of
Anarchy and Pacific Rim built Hunnam
into a star to watch punim followed up
the guillermo del toro blockbuster with
another del toro movie crimson peak and
later the critically lauded lost city of
Z unfortunately his luck was about to
run out with Hunnam as the face and
director Guy Ritchie at the helm King
Arthur legend of the sword was supposed
to be the start of a new franchise based
on the legendary character those plans
were hastily scrapped after the box
office numbers spelled disaster Warner
Brothers signed off on a 175 million
dollar budget but the film made less
than 40 million dollars domestically it
looks like in this case Hunnam wasn't
quite worthy to take the sword from the
Stone bullet once thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]